vrai appétit et brûle on a oublié la
chose d'appris avaler
pour la sauce
est vrai ça on va passer la journée
ensemble aujourd'hui klauk l'avion pour
aller au vestiaire pour la revisiter don
de l'association forum
[Musique]
bonfoh web c'est une association qu'on a
créé avec avec mes amis parce que
on vient tous dans nos milieux modestes
et on sait d'où l'on vient on était pas
on n'était pas très riche mais on
n'était pas très pauvres non plus mais
voilà on a eu quelques difficultés quand
on était petit mais on remercie le
bourget et surtout notre famille qui
nous ont beaucoup aidés et on sait que
quand on était petits on avait besoin
d'espoir on a besoin d'espérer que un
jour on deviendrait un jour on fera ça
un jour on fera si et si cet espoir
qu'on essaie dehors de donner aux gens
un
ces matériels très importants
à lui contre la couille vous avez marqué
ont du mal qu'on n'attend pas
on était venu au ministère pour
donner les tout le matériel qu'on a pu
acheter pour pour lutter contre locaux
vides on a donné des extracteurs
d'oxygène dégel des masques ont accompli
de grandes choses pour
pour pour une association aussi jeunes
que nous on a pu faire quelques
activités en france au sénégal et la sté
pour le moment c'est le plus gros qu'on
a fait
[Musique]
voilà c'est quoi c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on fait une action au sénégal c'est
comme si on est on est encore très jeune
voici la deuxième fois la dernière fois
on était partis au village
voit rappeler ce qui se passait là bas
et ceux dont les allées besoin leur
apporter notre soutien notre être
lisons bien acquis
c'est un beau moment de partage on était
toujours d'intégrer souvent qu'ajoie au
sénégal sur nos petits moments de faire
une action ou d'essayer de calais les
actions pendant pendant les périodes où
je suis au sénégal vu qu'avec
mon métier le foot j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps je passe pas souvent du temps au
sénégal donc à chaque fois qu'on vient
on essaie de faire un petit truc et la
terre gros truc on espère que la
prochaine fois que je vais venir y aura
encore un autre truc et
voilà mais on essaie de progresser
tranquillement c'est un voleur leblanc
il ya le regard josian vayre
vous allez monter la sauce en 5 secondes
oui
le président le président massif et on
vient de voilà il quartier où
la vie n'est pas rose ce départ bon elle
avance tout doucement on a fait un grand
pas j'ai pris que pour moi mais à trop
de personnes
mais
l'appétit ap ils vous prennent tous les
vides ça c'est des semaines où le témoin
temps soir what a pity soir des fois ce
soir soir soit savent aller vite
ça c'est le plus important jospin je
boot oublier tout ça
non plus
ça tu trouves pas à paris
tout le reste tu peux trouver peut-être
bien senti trop fort bien fermé
[Musique]